Ngay A miệng sâu tháng 1, tổng thống Mí đơn đơn trăm tiền bố năng thuế nhập khẩu đối với một số mắt hàng của Hàn Quốc,
gồm ôt tông, dược phần và gỗ sẻ, đứng mơ mơ lắm phần chăm lên hàng lắm phần chăm.
Ông cho biết quy định đứa đưa ra rồi có hội hạn Quốc chẳng phy dựa thỏa thuận thường mại sông phương.
Mà hai nhớ đến nhất chỉ đặt đường vào mùi hình ả ngoài.
Chỉ mạng sở hội chú xưa xồ, ông chẳng chỉ có hội hạn Quốc không thực hiện đúng thỏa thuận.
Đồng thời nhất lại rằng ông và tổng thống Hàn Quốc li tri mìa đả đạt 1 thuận rất tốt cho Hài Bên và ngày 8,
mấy thống bệnh năm 2018 và được tái khẩn định khi ông Trump tham Hàn Quốc, quay tháng 11.
Theo thuận này, Mỹ A tuyệt chung nếu hả hạn Quốc đổi lại xuống, các đồ tựa bài chăm là Mỹ tìa đổi là Mỹ vào Mỹ.
Vì hảnh Quốc chở biết chơi nhận được thông báo chính thân từ việc Washington,
tuy nhiên bộ trường thông mại nước này dự kiến sạm Mỹ để chào đổi.
Hàn Quốc hiện là một trong những đối tát thương mại quan trọng của Mỹ.
Chúng như năm 2020 đã nhập khẩu lượng hạn Quốc chỉ giá một trong tỉ đối là Mỹ từ quốc gia đường báo hả này.